[Music]
first I just want to thank you all for
being here you know um it's been a long
year for me for us it's Friday night I'm
tired
yeah I'm over here it is Friday night
right I was I was just just so impressed
to see you all here and paying such such
attention to this I know these are
important areas but you're you're giving
your time and it's valuable and I
appreciate it so thank you for sitting
here and listening to everything
appreciate hey there I'm a music
composer turned game designer track
product manager now working in mobile
games I got into mobile for this I mean
what you're talking about games is a
very powerful tool for change right
specifically from mobile a lot of what
you've been talking about is like VR AR
type seven it's a lot of like lab
setting stuff right yeah um I got I kind
of like ditched console games to get
specifically right into mobile most of
what we do is mobile it is okay yes I
didn't make that clear because it's fun
to talk about the VR stuff that we do
now but mobile its accessibility most of
all we do is mobile nice okay cool I
wanted to ask of so a prospective here
is people use the the via dodge if you
can measure it you can manage it right
I've always felt like if you can measure
it you can gamify it and I think I'm
very excited about what kind of info is
coming into phones and what kinds of
info is becoming available to mobile
apps mobile games right right I'm very
curious what what info we don't have yet
or that isn't consistent enough yet that
is going to be pivotal and really
changing the kind of impact useful
serious games can have through mobile
devices
yeah whatever texts coming there from
old stuff yeah it's a great question you
know we we have the most accessible
things to us are the concrete
performance metrics right the behaviors
that you do when you tap on something
when you shake something you know that's
obviously what most of us lot
- because it's quantifiable it's
discrete it's usually time locked by
that we mean it occurs in the context of
another event that it can be related to
so it's powerful I mean it's what every
tech company uses in some way or another
it's what we use in most of our work
what's what's elusive but so valuable is
a lot of what's going on under the hood
and it's not trivial in its potential
because although the outcomes might be
the same that's the speed of response
even the response that you make
given the factors that influence it or
that limit it we could we could really
create the type of experiences whether
it be entertainment or communication or
enhancement tools that are much more
powerful and much more appropriate for
the person we just often just don't know
what's under the hood where their
attention really lies what their
emotional setting is while they're
engaging we just don't really know and I
am really excited by the new sensor data
but as we know most of it just is
completely unable to inform me as a
medical professional in a lot of the
data just not being validated and not
knowing clearly how reliable how
sensitive how consistent it is so we
need to up our game in terms of sensor
data even in the consumer space so that
when we're you know just today I was as
in the gym and I was on the elliptical
and Adam works out every day is it in
the morning I mean five days minimum but
he blends cognition Evan if possible but
I think exercise is the most clear thing
- for cognition benefits but I had my
hands on the elliptical and I guess I
was touching the sensors I don't really
use it as as a sensor tool but it is
recording it and there's a message like
this information may this wasn't there
like a month ago because I would have
noticed it
this information may not be accurate as
for reference purposes only that's like
what how good it is is it that you know
then right and that's like part of the
problem it's like the ideas are there
but they are covering themselves because
if someone goes on there and then that
heart rate is not really reflective you
know then there's liability issues but
you know we see this but to me it was
just a reminder as like well I'm glad
I'm not recording and paying attention
to this data because I've been on this
thing for like the whole year and only
now is it telling me that basically say
this data is not reliable so you know
there is a lot of amazing physiological
recording that is possible and some of
it is only capable in very controlled
settings like we do in the laboratory
with very expensive equipment bridging
that divide is like a next big frontier
but that data telling your emotional
your your your attentional context your
memories will be valuable and dangerous
so with all great value comes danger
right there's always two sides to this
sword and it's really really evident to
me when you think about reading out
someone's memory attentional and
emotional context in the moment I mean
think about the good that could be done
with that but think about the dangers so
hi so my name is a via thank you so much
for being here tonight so I'm a college
student in my last year of school and I
was just wondering what kind of projects
in a are or maybe even VR do you see
kind of up-and-coming whether or not
they're related to the work you do that
you think could be super impactful and
if so like how would you suggest someone
get involved or even just learn more
like me cool great question
we're just starting to experiment with
AR I've advised for a company called
magically if you probably know about
them we have the device where where
we're figuring our way through the world
of AR I think there's great potential
there I'm excited about it but I haven't
come up with anything really clear that
we're investing our time in VR on the
other hand
the opportunity to create fully
controlled environments that are
immersive and engaging across all your
senses is just infinitely exciting to me
so two of the VR projects that we're
doing so we're trying to do things that
we're not just doing in VR because
they're cool to do in vehicles VR is
cool but things that we just can't do
outside of VR
so that's like always my charge to our
group it's like does this have to be in
VR if you could do this on a tablet why
would we do it in VR tablets are just so
much more accessible do it on a phone
what do we have to do in VR like where
is the true utility of this technology
so the two things that we're doing is a
game called labyrinth and a game called
coherence labyrinth is we take our
participant soon-to-be patients and we
put them in a 3d cityscape that they
have to learn and navigate by literally
moving their legs and and and walking
through it
it's Omni trim yeah omnidirectional
treadmill on an omnidirectional
treadmill
although the trackers with the vive are
really effective without the treadmill
so we're you know this technology is
just coming out so we're we're
constantly trying to be flexible but the
idea is like the one thing that fear
does really well is give you space which
you just can't get in the 2d format so
our memory systems the hippocampus
really evolved for spatial navigation
like we still are full of these place
cells and it's just part again of our
ancient brains the hypothesis that I
have is that if we could challenge your
spatial memory at a high enough level
and a real-world enough level we will
improve your memory performance outside
of that domain now that's a crazy
hypothesis if that's true it'll be
massive because we have like no tools
that really actually improve memory we
have we have memory like sort of
orthotics so like give you tricks to do
memory but not really improve memory
function itself and we're looking at
that in very early Alzheimer's disease
early dementia the other game would
create it as a game called coherence and
this was inspired by my friendship with
Mickey Hart from the Grateful Dead and
he has since we've been friends has been
talking about rhythm and music as as
treatments as Metis
and again another ancient experiencial
treatment that hasn't really had the
type of research data that's fully
convincing to regulatory agencies or
professionals that it's become medicine
just hasn't happened yet and a lot of it
is I think because we haven't put it
into these algorithms where we could
deliver them reproducibly and so what we
created was a closed loop system where
you're challenged rhythmically in a
three-dimensional space across visual
auditory and soon vibrationally where
you respond to rhythms with your entire
body and as you show competency and
mastery in terms of your accuracy and
your consistency the rhythms become more
complicated in many ways the hypothesis
is that because rhythm involves
anticipation and timing which are
abilities that our brain uses for
essentially everything it would be like
fine-tuning this machine and we'll see
benefits across the whole scope of
cognitive abilities hypothesis so those
are two VR projects that were interested
in you know there's so many different
touch points for the work we do our
Center has people with pretty much every
type of background you can imagine so it
depends what your interests are we do
all of our programming in unity which as
you know is available for anyone it's
really democratized game development and
we often work with like a team of like
two people even one person so learning
tools like that and understanding its
potential to help activate different
cognitive systems I think would be a
really exciting thing to do I'm uh thank
you for coming here today has been
fantastic I'm really interested in this
topic that you touched on a few times in
the the idea of the distracted mind the
sort of world of like Facebook and other
companies whose stock prices are largely
correlated to their ability to get
people stuck in a sort of a do loop and
so I'm so on one hand you know I I'm
very nervous that that social media
addictive social media and other forms
of internet attention-grabbing
mechanisms are
in some way sort of an existential
threat to mindfulness that that's that's
very interesting to me and you're
working on a lot of things that it seems
to me might might be the next wave of
vaccinations so I'm very interested on
this not just in the treatment side but
on the using digital medicine as a
vaccine yeah and so if that's the case
here's so I'm sorry I'm so sorry this
might take a second and I apologize to
everybody this is a question I promise
but if you if you can treat I don't have
the right terminology for this but if
you can if you can treat people's
intentions throughout their lives as a
weighted function
so each intention has a as a weight and
they build up over time some intentions
are more permanent than others
some are more recent than others there's
some kind of curve that can map all that
out and you also treat like future
desires like what you would want on your
deathbed like spending more time with
friends and family like there's some
kind of weighted future function there
as well and then we have the present
moment right where we have all the power
so present us has a disproportionate
amount of power relative to past us or
future us because we get to make the
decision right here in the moment and so
and you described it as a pause right
between the reaction and action so my
question to you is can we use digital
medicine to increase agency in that
moment and bye-bye but by both
vaccinating ourselves against invasive
memes or what have you and can we also
treat the loss of agency in the present
moment with digital medicine do you
think we can get it on both sides I sort
of what I'm asking yeah it's a great
question and really eloquently stated I
mean we it's sort of what we do you know
we we want to get out in front of things
as you know healthcare is really sick
care right that's a misnomer we don't
take care of healthy people we take care
of sick people had UCSF at every Medical
Center it's a it's a major problem right
you talk about the economy
of technology being misdirected you know
I'm just saying we have a challenge as a
hospital and that our entire economy is
built on you being sick right you being
well is not actually very financially
beneficial to us and I'm you know it's
just it's just another economic model
challenge that we face because what we
want to do is keep you healthy right
ideally right that's the mission so I
think that there's a ton to do in terms
of preventative tools that can detect
the most subtle changes and it relates
to your future plans how you view your
past that affect you in a way that may
be below your awareness level that could
just help you maintain a healthy mind
for your life so that's really what our
highest-level goals are to do it's very
hard to fix people when they're broken
in some ways it's much much more ideal
to keep people functioning well I mean
think about it like your car which is a
way simpler system right I mean that's
why you get two knobs right you prevent
that breakdown that's more expensive and
and more time-consuming and you could
lose your car but if you keep it at a
high level and I think we need a little
bit more of these mental tuneups and so
I don't know if that particularly
answers your question but that's sort of
the the dream goal is to have such a
sophisticated system I mean it's so much
more nuanced when you're looking for
changes in people that are healthy that
are early but that's where we hope to go
even right now like our ADHD study
people like some people don't respond to
that equally well right even though they
may have troubles with stimulants being
the only treatment to still like oh but
video games you know they still like
have this weight of like I hate that too
I hear it all and you know the the thing
that I always tell them is that these
games that we're creating as treatments
are not meant to make your child do a
certain thing or act a certain way
they're meant to give them control
that is the goal and that's what our
data suggests it's not like they're now
like attention focused machines that's
not what we're trying to do we're trying
to make them have the machinery to pay
attention when they want to we're not
even telling them when to pay attention
that could be an asset or a deficit
depending on how you look at it but
we're giving them the machinery that
when they decide I should be paying
attention they can so it's really
actually giving agency in a way in a way
that the drugs don't actually do very
well they don't really give the agency
they they they change the state in a way
that is comforting to some people
discomforting to others as opposed to
giving the choice I I think that's how I
did he Adam amazing talk amazing
technology and thank you for talking to
us about this my name is Aaron I told
you earlier that I have a background in
molecular neurobiology right so I'm very
interested in neuroplasticity and really
how that works on a molecular level but
I completely agree that terms of the
input just bombard in the brain with
small molecules with drugs is not the
way to really change the brain right and
so it's amazing that you're approaching
this from a more Gestalt kind of
holistic yeah although I started my PhD
was on NMDA receptors in the hippocampus
which are glutamate receptors involved
in the molecular mechanisms of
plasticity I mean that's where where I
came from absolutely that's how I got my
start in neurobiology too but so you
you're trying to but ultimately the
brain is changed by changes in biology
changes in gene expression changes in
molecular dynamics and so if you guys
are moving through clinical trials your
endpoint really is going to be a change
in plasticity correct and plasticity at
some sort of functional level so have
you guys identified any biomarkers or
any real molecular changes that can be
seen by putting people into these closed
looped yeah it's such a great question
you know we we don't really have access
to the molecular chemistry of people
really in a very crude way with PET
scans most of our biological match
tricks are related to functional imaging
either fMRI given its advantages and
limitations which I'm sure you're aware
and a lot of what we do is with EEG so
in our nature paper and we have a paper
in review right now we have a meditation
training game we didn't get to talk
about that sin in review right now we're
very excited about it closed loop
meditation basically using digital
technology but in the name of the game I
say the name of the meta train
Mediterranean aim of that game we
developed it with a jack Kornfield a
friend and and real leader in the
mindfulness and meditation world and
they're just like our nature paper EEG
is an outcome measure and so the main
thing that we look for are changes in
coherence you know what we all learn
when you if you had any neuroscience
training is that neurons communicate
with each other by these electrochemical
signals that go down the axons and then
through a synapse on a dendrite or
another neuron cell body send that
signal to the next neuron and on and on
and on that's true but what we have come
to realize is that another phenomena
involved in the transmission of neural
of data across the brain is related to
rhythm that neural if you look if you
take a step back from the neuron that
you have these what we call in Samba 'ls
of neurons that have these on and off
activations and in activations that lead
to oscillations of activity rhythms just
like everything in nature has these
rhythms and you could record these
that's what EEG records is these
oscillations of electrical activity in
the cortex of the brain one thing that
we've we've come to realize and I think
it's it's largely agreed upon at least
the neuroscientists I know and and we
certainly use this state a lot is that
when you have rhythms in two different
brain areas that become synchronized
coherent rhythms phase-locked right like
try to talk to someone when you're not
in the same phase it's really difficult
same way with brain areas if they
communicate with each other out of phase
the
the transmission of data is less
effective and so one of the things that
we look for in a lot of our data is
coherence in rhythms across brain
regions and at different frequencies so
these type of metrics that are you know
more sophisticated ways and getting more
sophisticated all the time of using
neural data in in humans become
essentially our functional biomarkers
and we could see them change with
different conditions the brain basically
becomes dis rhythmic in many types of
conditions and that's sort of a lot of
inspiration around some of the rhythm
work we're doing is to see if that helps
create greater coherence of cost in the
brain death that's the name of that game
but that's what we've been using but you
know we I have colleagues that work on
animal models of a lot of these things
where you do have much easier access to
the chemistry of the brain and so we do
have collaborations with other groups
trying to find you know some of the
molecular underpinnings of the types of
changes that we're seeing
yeah it's one of the things we haven't
done yet we've done a lot of things but
I am interested in it we just we
actually collect sap blood samples from
almost everyone in our studies now in
the future design once we know exactly
the type of genetic markers that we'd be
looking for so we're preparing for it
but we haven't done it yet but it's a
great thought yeah that'd be great great
um first of all great talk and I feel
kind of privileged to live in a time
where it's possible to discuss all these
things and to think outside of the box
I'm a post my name is Larissa I'm
opposed to at UCSF at the Department of
Psychiatry and currently I'm thinking
about putting in a grant to actually
look at increasing treatment for
substance use disorder and mental health
using VR and for that I just wanted to
ask you substance use is kind of
something you left out in your yeah
experiences and I wanted to ask what we
have experiences and what your
recommendations would be when addressing
these kinds of problems and I'm coming
from Switzerland so I'm coming from a
recreate or environment where harm
reduction is actually implemented in
drug policy and this is what I want to
see like around the world who actually
meets the people where they're at and I
believe that VR can have a huge
possibility or it's a great opportunity
to actually bring people closer to the
treatment where we want to have them
yeah that's great we should definitely
talk about two Maps yeah out of out of
this context I'd love to talk to you we
we get a lot we've just recently started
getting a lot of interests from
addiction researchers so one thing I
want to make clear like all those
conditions I listed the reason we focus
on them is because someone that knows
those populations really well that gets
what we do that sees the connection
reaches out to us we really don't start
collaborations because a we have a lot
of incoming and we find the best
collaborations are when we have a
motivated partner and there's so much to
do so we're really just waiting for the
right
diction researcher to start these
collaborations so it makes sense I have
tons of ideas related to addiction we
have a new game called engage which is I
won't go into detail now but basically
it starts with the normal super rich
videogame environment and then rewards
you by switching to a much more
impoverished slower less frequent reward
environment basically we make 10
year-olds meditate but despite the fact
that they're not aware that they are
it's really it's really awesome to watch
and so we think that there could be a
lot of benefits in in addiction research
because of this re the shifting of the
reward systems that we think that we're
accomplishing so that's one game that we
have that I would love to do addiction
work on we haven't done it yet we do
have a lot of collaborators including
insulin and Luzon
I don't know if you're from Luzon but
the issue of is a hospital that we work
very closely with we actually have two
collaborations with that group but yeah
I'm happy to talk to you offline about
it hi my name is Ashley I was curious to
hearing how your experience driven
cognitive drug would impact the
therapeutic industry therapy essentially
whether it be working in tandem with
your product or with like cognitive
behavioral therapy like therapy yeah we
don't know we also don't know how it's
gonna impact the pharmaceutical industry
so I told you what I know I have a
really long list of things I don't know
that I'm happy to share with you we
don't know how our treatment will
interact with synergistically or
antagonistically with pharmaceuticals
with other forms of therapy we don't
know the minimal viable dose of our
treatment don't know we don't know how
often we have to reduce people we
there's a lot of things we don't know we
have a lot of work to do you know this
is first step one is that we've shown a
benefit with a certain modality all of
the children
with ADHD that were in that trial was
not on any treatment at all it's
actually very easy to find children like
that we have six million children
diagnosed with ADHD in our country alone
two million of them are taking no
treatment and never have two million had
but they withdrew from it for all sorts
reasons than two million are on a
treatment and so treatment being
stimulants really when it comes down to
it for this
this description so I think that in the
setting of what I describe to you that
our goal is to make this machine
stronger behavioral treatments whether
they're human interaction or digital
behavior is going to be really important
I think it's an important piece of this
that we haven't done a ton of work on
but I think that bridge so in other
words sometimes I always make this
analogy like we're giving this kid a
Ferrari
we're like here's your new brain we just
tuned it up now you could get that car
and leave it in the garage you can't get
it and drive it like [ __ ] and crash it
on your first day like I think we need a
bridge between this more fine-tuned
machine that they have and their ability
to use it in the real world and that's
where I think some type of behavioral
intervention whether it's digital or not
is gonna be critical to get the maximal
utility out of what we're giving them
yes I'm wondering if you have any
experience to share with us and people
doing active research for decades on
this Pam Omidyar for example on hope lab
on children that are challenged with you
know cancers and stuff and and so it's a
virtual reality trying to give them help
you know hopeful and and and tuning them
into you know responding to different
drugs and medication the other is like
DARPA that's been working for many years
on high-performance teams you know like
the Blue Angel fighter pilots and the
virtual reality's and and how a team can
be very effective so it's not just the
cognitive of an individual but it's
the team and the third area is someone
like Mary Lou Jepsen now that it's
looking for a major breakthrough and
that's a million times higher resolution
than functional MRI through optics
narrow infrared optics and she believes
that if she can do this and that they'll
be able to read and write thoughts and
the human brain opened up a pathway of
telemetry between people the bandwidth
you'll be able to share communicate
through Holograms what your dreams are
what your thoughts are and are you
involved or so I know all of those
groups and all those people and I can
answer quite simply by saying you know I
love it all I think it's great that we
have innovation across so many different
domains
I mean basically I told you my story
here and the work that we're doing but
we're part of a way bigger ecosystem
that I really haven't talked about in
great detail but you know I'm largely
agnostic with a lot of the tools we use
someone comes out like Mary Lou with a
better non-invasive brain recording
device I'll be using it tomorrow and you
know so we're really flexible on the
things we use I've known Hope labs from
the beginning we don't pretend that
we're the only game in town or that
we're we're gonna answer all the
questions and you know we're always
looking for partners whether it's at
nerve escape or achillea or jazz door
investments so you know where you've
really got my story here but you know
extrapolate out all these innovative
companies and individuals like I'm so
happy they exist I wish there were a
thousand more of them but you know it
takes you know an army to do this like
one company one lab one person not going
to change the world we need more and
that's a lot of why I do travel around
the world is to find those groups in
form we have this group called the neuro
scape alliance where we create like this
international consortium of groups that
our luzon connection to like all of us
raise the tide and then all all the
ships are at a higher level so that's
that's really the goal so yeah I know
all those groups and I think they're
doing great work love it that was that's
a wrap to the Q&A segment you guys know
we talked a lot about top-down
processing goal-setting and execution
stay focused
build the future I love you all thank
you for coming
much love
[Applause]
[Music]